les beaux jours sont bien loin du temps
où les quatorze bhns rouler leur
arrivait souvent repoussé avait mis les
nerfs de beaucoup à rude épreuve
puis le ciel s'est éclairci jusqu'à
décembre 2018 selon la cftc le
délégataire accuse martinique transport
autorité délégante de vouloir mettre fin
au contrat 700 emplois à la clé c'est le
début du désamour
seule l'autorité délégante à la faculté
de résigner c'est ce qu'elle a indiqué
c'est ce qu'elle souhaite il est grand
temps que le jeu du chat et de la souris
dans lequel jeu dans lequel nous sommes
là sourires s'arrête et que il ya une
décision à prendre
soit il y as résignation soit il n'ya
pas résignation
cette bhns hors service sur les 14 le
trafic est perturbé et ne devrait pas
s'améliorer de sitôt
la faute à des batterie défaillante
elles ne seront remplacés que dans
quatre mois
l'autorité délégante est visé par la cft
eu qui évoquent clairement des
obligations non assurés nous avions
demandé la prise en charge du
remplacement de ses batteries
à ce jour nous n'avons pas reçu nous
n'avons pas ce matériel à notre
disposition nous avions également
demandé un certain nombre de réparations
sur le réseau électrique de sorte à ce
que ces batteries soient entretenus par
la mise en charge nocturne qui est prévu
cela n'a pas été fait martinique
transports joint par téléphone ne
comprend pas le procès qui lui est fait
ces incertitudes pèsent sur la masse
salariale
les syndicats ont sollicité ce jour un
entretien avec la présidence de
martinique transport pour lever le voile
sur la situation et s'assurer de la
préservation des emplois